well good evening from London welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored I'm sick of
talking about them honestly I am I think
most of us are but they can't stop
yapping about themselves and putting
themselves into the news agenda so we
have to this is Harry and Megan who've
now regelled us with their truth so far
in sycophantic interviews with Oprah
Winfrey with James Gordon with Stephen
Colbert they've bashed Britain in six
hours of indulgent whining on Netflix so
front did Bob gas on their self-centered
versions of History Harry has barely
finished the global family trashing
tourism support of his treacherous
family trashing Memoir but never to be
he's decided that the world hasn't heard
quite enough from him
so Harry's latest wheeze is a live
therapy session with Dr Gable Marte have
fated to trauma expert in which he
reminded us again that he Harry is the
world's biggest victim
and then at some point you say towards
the end of the book
when is someone in this family going to
break free and live if you don't know
I have now yeah
um
it was great I do I I mean once the book
came out I felt I felt incredibly free I
felt a huge weight off my shoulders oh
shut up
fans paid 20 pounds each you imagine
paying for that for 90 minutes of that
psychobabble in which Harry revealed you
began therapy after a row with Megan and
again divulges his fondness for drugs
I started doing it recreationally he
says and I started to realize how good
it was for me he's talking about
psychedelic narcotics I would say it's
one of the more fundamental parts of my
life that changed me and helped me deal
with the traumas and pains of the past
well there's been an advert not taking
drugs it's old Harry isn't it U.S border
agents take a dim view of drug use by
non-us citizens Nigella Lawson is once
banned from flying to America ultimately
she'd take in cocaine another compelling
reason why we don't want them at the
king's coronation we might end up being
stuck with them for good
well this unfortunately worded caption
of the story but time said it best at
the end of the talk with Prince Harry Dr
Gable Marte said he was suffering from
PTSD ADHD depression anxiety and panic
disorder no reports on what Harry's
suffering from after that uh so we're
all
I think feeling the same way which is
enough
surely enough and yet it won't be will
it they're just going to keep going
and going and going
depicting themselves as the world's
greatest victims whilst pocketing
hundreds of millions of dollars to
describe their life victimhood
there's no end to the self-indulgent
arrogance from the sussexes and their
Grievances and they've now announced
that they've been in email
correspondence over their attendance at
the king's coronation but and I quote
exactly an immediate decision on whether
the Duke and Duchess will attend will
not be disclosed by us at this time
think about that response for a moment
for lack of self-awareness is
jaw-dropping they've been invited to the
new monarch of Britain's coronation and
they'll go back to them with an answer
when they've thought about it
is there any wonder that their
popularity is plummeting on both sides
of the Atlantic is it any wonder they
become objects of such Global ridicule
Comedian Chris rocks become a ladies
coming to Target Megan and Harry and his
new Netflix special
sometimes it's just a minute
because she's complaining I'm like
talking about nobody they're so racist
they wanted to know how Brown the baby
was gonna be that's not racist
cause even black people want to know
how Brown the baby gonna be
well the substances have been on what
they call a journey when it comes to
their claims of racism and their royal
family first they're sensationally
accused the royal family directly of
racism then they tried to Gaslight us
into believing they never accused the
royal family racism is all the terrible
media who've done that now it's
increasingly clear just about nobody
takes any of these claims seriously
anymore Harry ended his therapy session
by addressing their ruthless mockery in
a recent episode of South Park the more
they criticized me he said the more I
need to share oh my God
so same time tomorrow Harry if you keep
lying we'll keep having to cover it
well joining me now is author and
historian Tessa Dunlop who just flicked
something weird across the desk there in
her Fury at my monologue activist and
BLM organizer Iman ayton and talked to
be contributor Esther Krakow and the
Sunday Times Royal editor Royal Nikki I
want to start with because Roy you broke
the story that the king's office has
sent an emailed invitation to the
coronation for Harry and Megan but their
response to me said it all just the
arrogance of saying yeah we've got it
and we'll come back to you when we
decided what we want to do
it was an interesting response um it
wasn't quite the response I suppose I
was expecting um I was just very keen
and asked and asked and asked whether or
not they had received an invite
um and got it very late on Saturday
night that they had in fact been invited
by The King and I suppose that's the
olive branch that everyone has been
waiting for there has been so much
speculation about whether or not they
were going to be invited and then come
but of course now everyone is going to
be waiting to see if they both come if
just Harry comes of course it's Archie's
fourth birthday on the day so there is
there is that to take into account um
but yeah we now wait and see when they
might RSVP to the king I mean like you
say an Olive Branch from the king and a
big one frankly because you know he's
just had to put up with all this
trashing in the book about him about his
wife Camilla about his son William about
gay all of them got it in this book so
he made the olive branch which is seen
as the decent thing for him to do
although I wouldn't uh recommend that he
do it if they if they come we're going
to have the circus the entire time
they're over and it will in some way
overshadow the coronation not completely
but it will certainly cast a shadow if
they don't come my view is well all
right we'll have a bit of noise about
them not coming but there won't be that
shadow they'll be in California nowhere
near the action when it happens isn't
the smart play for everybody that they
just stay in Montecito
the thing is I think the king wouldn't
have issued that invite unless he
actually really really wanted his son
there um he wants his son there I think
the other thing we saw with the Platinum
Jubilee service last year for her
majesty the Queen the late queen of
course is that they did come over and
they were actually able after all the
hullabaloo of earlier last year after
Oprah and all of that they were able to
actually come to parts of it and stay
out of the Limelight I think the other
thing to remember here is a coronation
is a once in a generation massive deal
there will be golden carriages there
will be 2 000 people in The Abbey it
will be an extraordinary site Harry and
Megan yes okay there's a bit of a circus
around them but I think all eyes will be
on the king and queen and everything
else that's going on that day and the
rest of the royal family so I think it's
doable I don't think that if they come I
don't think they're going to completely
steal the show they didn't last year for
the Platinum Jubilee it can be done well
I hope you're right uh Roya but another
cracking scoop congratulations in the
Sunday Times appreciate you joining me
thank you very much uh okay let's get
into this Iman
the Chris Rock thing first of all did
make me laugh out loud because of course
I was accused of being a racist for not
believing all this racism garbage that
she was coming out with now Chris Rock
has said it is he a racist okay well we
have to put everything that he said into
contacts fast okay so he said there
everyone wants to pay the victim and he
also referred to white men being the
most recent culprits alongside Meghan
Markle he also said that Megan had a won
the light skin lotteries and otherwise
she has light skin privilege and so
therefore you couldn't quite understand
why she was still complaining he also
said that she was acting dumb in regards
to the royal family and that's when he
proceeded to say that they were the
original racist they invented
colonialism and they were the ogs of
racism so in other words racism should
be expected so he basically spent the
best part of his set making it that
clear that the royal family were a bunch
of racists and that Megan markle's
ignorance well he was eluding basically
utterly Ludacris he was alluding to
colonialism and you can certainly frame
an argument that there was obviously
racism and colonism I can accept that
well we're talking about the current
members of the royal family being
directly accused of racism Esther and
what really annoyed me about Harry
retracting that was that two years of
damaging allegations left to hang around
the world that the Royals had been
racist and then he turns around and said
well you're never meant to be right well
then I always made the point that he
didn't know what he was talking about
because he he started trying to wade
into a conversation that was way out of
his debt saying he was unconscious bias
and I often made the point that hold on
you've let these allegations stew for
two years saying that there was concern
about the darkness of your child even
people that are not particularly fond of
anything to do with racial politics
would say that is racist right but then
you need to turn around and say actually
the media said that it was racist and
that we we are suddenly so so so blind
and all we do is follow the meat that we
can't actually discern this for
ourselves that's when everyone on both
sides of the debate said you don't know
what you're talking about you know what
I'm just using your wife yeah look I
mean we've talked about this a lot I
feel like Prince Harry here like the
white plonker do you know
[Laughter]
when I left Good Morning Britain I think
I've talked about this before but when I
left good morning bro it's because
specifically I didn't believe Meghan
markle's claims that she'd gone to
someone at the palace and said she was
suicidal and they said she couldn't get
any treatment or therapy or help and
also I didn't believe the racism claims
now what's interesting is neither of
those hang on Tessa here's my point
neither of those claims get repeated in
Harry's 420 page book it's like they
never happened and yet they were the
incredibly incendiary and explosive
allegations which triggered this whole
thing
what happened to them where did they go
it's a question of nuance I am very
clearly a white woman but I am married
to a foreigner at the bottom of the
European pecking order a Romanian and I
remember and my my a wider family deny
this I remember my aunt her little pink
fist banging on the table our country is
too full we don't want him over here I
remember the way they spoke to him such
as some members not all members of my
friend with a louder voice like he was a
tradesperson coming in the back door in
the 1950s this stuff it filters in it's
very hard to prove it's hard to
articulate and we're talking about white
on white and the context
right okay I know I've I I've I've
explained something about that but I'm
talking about anything but it's very
hard to articulate they're hard to prove
and they're actually
um what happens is they get labeled they
get pigeonholed they get pushed I'm
sorry sorry hang on actually I believe
Harry when he said he felt something
I've hung around public school boys I've
been in a group yeah that's fine
well no that's what I'm talking about
they went on global television to Oprah
Winfrey the most famous people in the
world yeah and they made direct
allegations of racism that they now have
said they simply didn't mate we didn't
mean to say enormous racist they've
never named anybody who they originally
said said these things nothing it
doesn't appear in the book it's just
vanished after two years of incredible
damage to the brand of the monarchy and
I just say the agenda's changed I just
want to just throw that point in I've
said this several times their agenda has
changed peers and so therefore their
tactics are too and so that is why it's
no longer in the book because I promise
right now is about getting it should
they have the goal to turn up at the
coronation bear in mind these two have
done so much to damage the institution
of the monarchy in the last three years
why would they even want to be there
celebrating the coronation of our next
game well first they think it is more
than possible to highlight racism with
an institution whilst simultaneously
wanting to reconnect with your family
that's the first point secondly but is
that what I did did they highlight
racism
that was the original plan to highlight
racism we already know that they have
backped rules with that yeah so there
was no race we already know that and in
terms of the coronation well it's
Archie's birthday as we already know so
it's for me personally yeah
four-year-old kid's birthday party
versus foreign
Esther apparently they've done this
deliberately decoration it's a really
Nazi perfect I do see that argument
there could be Merit there because if
they say they're not coming because of
Archie's birthday
what we've got is to me they're like
teenagers and teenagers often make
really good points there at the front of
pushing the envelope forward they've
made their case sometimes in articulate
sometimes clumsy sometimes egregiously
okay now they're in their bedroom right
and we need them to come out the bed no
we don't yes they need to climb down
because Mommy and Daddy at the table
want them absolutely no yes if you do
the metaphor and by the way here's the
other point we do it's not just about
what the king wants because it's his son
it's about what the king should do is
the right thing for the country that's
what I wanted the king represents all of
us right I don't think the most people
in Britain want Harry Megan anywhere
near
the Commonwealth can I just say I don't
think that this is in terms of the
crying Nation I don't think this is
simply just about whether King Charles
wants them there or whether Harry and
Megan wants to do that I actually think
this is due to reputation management and
I think it comes down to what is best
for the institution and I believe what
is best is uh all right do you think
they should be there Redemption yes or
no I think that can Charles should
prioritize
within his family show I think they
should go I don't think they should go I
think it's it's this is something for
the British public I'm I'm quite frankly
I'm sick of The Saga I'm sick of the
drama I'm sorry for the issues that
they're having but this should be
happening Behind Closed success if they
do come they do come here's what they're
going to do they're going to bring a
camera crew they're going to bring
recorders and they're going to invade
the privacy of the royal family all over
it is and here's what's going to be the
winners the royal family will win if
they come they will win if they come and
you press the populist press will win
Pierce so it's all gone to get them on
those pews I shall no longer the popular
press I'm a television presenter of a
show called Piers Morgan uncensored
interesting yeah uh well look I'm glad
we all reached an agreement that I'm
Ryan
delusions on Pandora right one thing for
sure if they do come it will be of
course a story and we will of course be
compelled to govern